we're gonna have a look at the Elliott
903 it's a machine that we did have a
very quick look at when we did our last
video here when we had a look around
generally at the museum but what we're
going to do is actually turn it on have
a closer look at it and see what it does
and talk about how how useful it is to
us here at the museum because the reason
why I like this machine so much is
because it's it's from 1966 and it's
pretty much the earliest machine in the
museum that we can still have up and
running and reprogramming it just as it
was then we do have some older kit
around here as well but for the most
part we don't quite have the expertise
yet to get it back up and running so
they're kind of inanimate objects but
this particular machine we have great
fun with we're going to turn it on we're
going to see what it does and so I think
we'll go straight into that
I heard a big noise when you started
what was that yeah well we have fans
kicking normally but the really big
noise that sounds like a motor revving
is coming from if I just move these
things around it's coming from in here
which is the punch tape printer because
we're going to load new programs on this
using punch tape and this is the
original printer with it of course so
you're just running out blank tape here
punching the new programming which is
also another fun thing that I like
explained to school kids when we have in
that this is exactly the same as copy
pasting a file onto a CD is just a way
of putting a new program onto a portable
storage medium
now we're cheating a little bit with
this computer originally it would have
been running with a teleprinter where
we've got a video screen here because it
keeps running costs a little bit lower
so that's not quite authentic but all
the actual workings of the hardware is
exactly as it was so it should all be
set up and ready to run the program and
there we are
well this one is at the moment it's not
playing the most mathematically advanced
program in the world it's playing
noughts and crosses for us this was
actually written in 2013 this program so
again not quite authentic to the time
but of course the hardware is still as
original as it ever was
although we have some people who say we
should do more serious computing
applications with these machines and we
totally agree with that we do so do some
more serious stuff we find that for
guided tours with school groups and so
on it's really good just to have little
fun distractions they can more
immediately engage with alongside the
kind of more serious number-crunching
stuff so I'm on this one we can play a
little game with lots and Cross's will
set it off the computers going to decide
where to move
sure enough it's going to take the
classic gambit of going right in the
middle which now means that it's
impossible to win okay and we can choose
let's go at this point so I'm going to
go in the bottom-left corner down there
now although it is impossible to beat
the machine at this game we have lots
and lots of school kids who will
nevertheless try and do just that
they will play the game through
completion they'll inevitably draw or
lose and then most of them all want to
try and have another go at it
unfortunately I have to move the guided
tours on there at that moment really so
yeah we we could play a lot of games of
noughts and crosses if we just left them
to it the grid is just numbered one to
nine and you just select the appropriate
number of depending on where you want to
go so here I'd better block him off so
that's number eight down there so there
we go
it could take a while it could yeah when
I first started doing these these guided
tours we are actually using the Elliot
and turning it on and so on I was a bit
concerned at first that this would be a
bit slow and the kids would lose
interest and they'd run off and go and
play on the snares instead and but
actually no they find it quite
entertaining and they do immediately
engage with it especially the younger
kids as well and in fact you know going
right up to teenagers who we'd expect to
be a bit a bit more surly a bit more
grumpy about the whole thing but um but
no it's surprisingly engaging a little
bit of software this and yeah as I
mentioned lots of people will try and
beat the computer and inevitably fail so
I'll make one last move we'll go in the
top corner and then we might try another
program on it I think firstly I need to
reset the machine so we'll stop this
simulation going here fiddle with the
switches in it it's relatively
straightforward it's just switching it
previously we have all of these ones up
and these two down to change it into a
mode where we can read new tape we're
just switching it around and that's
relatively simple it's a good thing as
well because I can just say to the kids
you get in touch you press that switch
for me you do this and that because it's
quite straightforward so that's always
nice letting them get hands-on with it
so what we then need to do is pick a new
program so I think well yeah we'll go
for this one there way up so we start
off with the black bit and then we get
to the actual code at the end there so
what we're going to do is put it through
that
I'm wrap it yeah we've got a bit of a
squirrel going on here I did once have a
tape that got so twisted and tangled
that we couldn't run it through the
little motor we've got here to wind it
back up again
and a colleague and I literally had to
spend about an hour just undoing each
little crease in the tape so we could
get it wrapped back up again and it's
safe to say we haven't used that tape
since right now we should be a bit sake
us so they aren't so we set the machine
this light sugar mum hurry up so we got
the red lamp that's appeared there which
means we're all ready to go
I press read and and as soon as this
tape is finished running throw the new
program will launch on BDU there so this
is exactly the same in principle as
plugging in USB stick plugging in a CD
it's just a way of reading new programs
from from a storage medium so it gets to
the end and new program starts just
beneath the end of knots and crosses
there so this one as you can see is the
countdown numbers game solver we've
moved away from lots and crosses we're
into a bit more complicated mathematics
now so I can just pick six numbers give
it a target it will compute those
numbers to try and hit the target just
as in the countdown numbers game so
let's pick something at random
and it's going to try and get 937 away
out so now it's going to try and work
out how to do it it can't do it using
just one number or two what's going to
happen now is the big thing that we've
got here the noise which sounds like the
machine is horrendously broken is in
fact fine this is just the noise that
the machine makes when it's computing
same as just any old strange beeps you
might get from your computer when it's
working something else so but the
problem with this machine is that
because it's from 1966 it's not quite as
powerful as something we have today it
takes a long time to crunch these
numbers so if I've given it something
quite difficult it can't do it using
using four of the numbers it's trying to
do it with five now and it gets longer
and longer the more of those numbers it
has to use so if it can't do it with
five it will try and do it with six and
that could take I could take anything up
to two or three minutes I think for it
to work out the the calculation the
beeping is it's just the speaker on the
back it does have audio capacity but
it's it's just yeah it's kind of like
the beeps you get on a motherboard it's
just to signify that the machine is
currently functioning is trying to
crunch those numbers it doesn't like it
this one is too hard what we'll do
instead is we will stop that program
running I need to reset it now because I
need to put it back in the mode to read
the program that's already in there
rather than running from a new tape so
we'll switch it round again and the
countdown program starts again I'll give
it something easy this time I'll give it
some nice big even numbers five ten to
six three and fifty and it's got to try
and get 480 that seems like a nice round
set of numbers for it to try and work
out so this time hopefully it's going to
manage it for us
there we go it's done it works out how
to do that ten times 50 minus 2 so 10
times 48 equals 480 there you go so that
one was a bit simple at that time I
should have given it something a bit
easier to work out first time around but
you did get to see just how hard this
machine finds it to do numbers that
modern computers would just do
instantaneously and so that's one of the
more interesting kind of mathematical
programs that we have it doing and I
think we'll run one more and we'll get
it to do something fun again this one's
going to come out I need to wrap it up
of course so put it in here
turn this on here we go
I haven't got a paper cut yet from this
one day I probably will and there we are
that's that one all sorted out for us so
I will leave that there feel it probably
in a minute and we'll put one last tape
in to line up the tape again
change it back into the mode where it's
reading programs instead of reading from
memory the red lamp comes on and there
we go once again it will launch straight
into the program as soon as this is done
this time it's not going to appear on
the monitor it's a slightly different
form of output this time round we'll
find out in just a moment
and a real that hole-punch tape is just
used to make it play the entertainer say
we like to change from the serious
programs that kind of crunch numbers
show kids how the computer is doing some
serious mathematics and so I'll give
them an idea of what it might have done
in its proper function when it was in
use in 60s and 70s but then we also like
to show them through kind of fun music
and through little games and so on and
give them an idea of how engaging this
sort of stuff can be so there we are
that's the Elliott 9:03 move to
Bletchley Park here in early 1944 and
came into action pretty soon thereafter